gang baby gang
um
good to be here happy
february
if you believe in it
if you practice it
you know i know a lot of folks out there
don't really uh
you know the calendar isn't their thing
they do they just kind of go on time
overall
you know
start finish you know they just
they're more that headstone is really
their thing that's their clock
they're not on the calendar like we are
but if you celebrate february
and you believe in it then
then
uh then i'm similar to you and happy
february
um
[Music]
you know i was thinking when i was
growing up they had a fella named
jean
was his name
and his name was eugene
but they didn't people didn't
nobody thought much of them
so they just called him gene because
they didn't want to
you know probably waste the time on the
on the the baguette the extra part of
his name it just said i'm calling him
gene you know
it felt ain't worth the time
and um
and he had the thinnest skin i mean damn
you wouldn't even
you'd ask him before you cut on a light
bulb around him
his skin is so damn thin you i mean just
my god
you know you could see you could see
what was going on
you could see his heart had just pumped
and it was heading to his hand and it
was heading back
you know come the blood you could see it
commuting
in him that's how he was just
his skin so thin
you know if he was gonna get a pimple
hell you knew before you could tell in
advance you you just see it form it just
thin skin really
i don't know if maybe his uh you know
when his parents had made love or
whatever they didn't really do it good
enough or well i don't know what
happened
you know i'm not a scientist
but um
but yeah you'd see you know i remember
one time he uh tried to do a cigarette
and he had to smoke it from so far away
he had to just lean his neck out and get
the tip of it because he couldn't get
his body that close to the flame
because he'd feel that heat
you know and he was always umbrellaed up
people keep him umbrella up
and so he couldn't do any outdoor sports
you know
jane you know
gene couldn't do no outdoor sports
because the sunlight would just he'd
lose before he started
you know
he'd be at the starting line he'd write
finish on that [ __ ] and lay down he
just couldn't handle the because his he
only had so much skin
and that's who he was you know and
and everybody thought he wasn't worth
much
you know they didn't even call him his
full name
and then we kind of got to an age i
think it might have been 9 or 11 or even
could have been seven
and when swimming was big you know
people you know
swimming when i was really you know
swimming was just
you know i didn't know anybody that had
a pool till i was probably
i don't know maybe
13 probably anyway swimming came out
and gene got in the pool
swimming was indoors
and so the sun the elements they weren't
they were that wasn't an issue
and dude
since he only had a few layers of skin
he probably had three and a half layers
of damn skin on him you know he was just
so thin skinned that
the wall you know because the body is
what
79 water probably
you know if you if you haven't had
anything to eat i bet it's even a little
more than that once you put lunch in
your body i bet it probably drops down
to about 79
but
uh
but anyway once he you know so your body
is that much water
once gene got in the pool man
dude
it was
he was his skin there was nothing no
there was hardly nothing between him and
the water of the pool and the water of
his body
and he was just like a damn i mean
just like a little salamander
you know that had just won a damn
scratch off and he was running that
[ __ ] back in there
i mean he would ju he
i mean he just uh
he's that good
you know uh
it just took a while sometimes sometimes
it takes a while
you know you don't know what
you don't know why whatever you're doing
why it is
or what you have you don't know
why you have it
you know
you don't know why you have it
you know you might have one arm and so
you know forever you're like damn dude
you know where's my other arm
and then somebody comes along and just
tells you to hold something
anyway let's get into it baby
[Music]
well i just broke up with my baby
he's on the camera
and there you go right there that's
eddie uh
that's 89 volts
with the come up
and um
yeah good to be here happy to p to be
back on a solo episode
uh thank you guys for your patience um
what's been happening a lot
a lot occurred over the past
i think it's been maybe six weeks
uh since i was in here doing solo
and um
i want to thank everybody for their
support
uh
through messaging through
um mail
you know we've got a lot of uh
you know hard mail
you know um
you know boxed box type thoughts boxed
messaging
and uh
you know
licked me licked mail
that people sent and i just want to say
thank you for that
um we'll do a uh anthrax challenge soon
and open that up
and also i want to thank you guys for um
i want to thank you for uh
just the support
and coming out to the shows over the
past
six months
you know um
as the tour was kind of getting its feed
and
you know the old special was the was
coming out and the new material was
making its way in
it was a lot of transition
and um
and man this weekend this past week we
went to florida and i felt like it was
the wheels were on baby
i felt like that thing was in four-wheel
drive
so uh
just thank you to everybody that's come
out in the different cities um at the
end of last year and just for the
support
i know a lot of you guys come you don't
even care about the comedy you just care
you just want to show support
you know and i feel that i want to let
you know i feel that and uh
yeah and just
i want to thank a lot of you guys just
for loving my for for for loving me when
i couldn't even love myself at times
you know um
i want to thank you for that
so uh
it's hard for me to feel that kind of a
it's hard for me to feel it it's hard
for me to feel when people care but um
i'm doing my best and i and i see it and
uh
and thank you i just want to say thank
you very much for that support
um what's going on man
well a lot uh
what have i so
here i wrote down some stuff in here so
just so i could have some idea
um things to talk about how i spent my
january so
um
well a lot of things i mean i i i'm
mostly
you know i i haven't
uh
i haven't felt good for a long time
you know i haven't felt good i have for
a couple years has something had been
bothering me
and i've talked about it on here and
um
something had been bothering me i just
felt uh
i think there was a couple things going
on one i was exhausted
and then two something was really
bothering me and i couldn't tell exactly
what it was or
what things it was it was like a damn
group of goblins i felt like
and they were hanging out just
just under the earth i just kept
it was like i had this
a lot of anger and i didn't know why
um
and one of the things that was going on
i wanted to i thought that i was getting
all i wanted to get off antidepressants
because i thought that was preventing me
from having a lot of my feelings
you know i thought it was preventing me
from
[Music]
uh
getting figuring out what was going on
with myself
like on the interior
because
i couldn't access my feelings
you know the antidepressants kept me at
like a comfortable space
and it felt like there was stuff that
was under there
and then also i was noticing about like
trying to be in love or um
[Music]
or
you know with relationships and dating i
was having trouble getting into like a
any other mode than just
wanting to be you know doing touch or
you know jerking each other or whatever
you know or just one of you know
i was getting you know and then
the female v you know what i'm saying
like so that's what i'm saying but
um yeah i was having a tough time with a
lot of that so so i wanted to get off
antidepressants and so that was kind of
spooky
because damn well you get off
antidepressants
you hitchhiking son
you hitch hiking
you know what i'm saying man i before
that i was in a i was in an uber
i was i was sitting in the back seat
having me a couple uh
you know takis or whatever you know
fritos chili cheese flavored and i don't
like them but i accidentally picked
those up instead of the regular bag
because the bags look too similar
so anyway i'm sitting back you know i
was in the lord's uber baby i was on
antidepressants
but you get off them [ __ ] you
standing on the side of the
road
yo [ __ ] is raw
you got your thumb out baby it's cold
and it's cold
um
and i thought i was gonna take a break
and go off to do some do a treatment
center but i couldn't uh i started
working with therapists heavily and i
couldn't figure out like what do i want
to go for like what is my real
issue what is really and i didn't know
so
you know i don't want to end up in some
center for damn you know
people that can't see well but i can you
know
but i'm seeing pretty decent you know i
don't want to
be in there doing like you know
that little chart the e m
you know
leftwardy upward e
and i'm just [ __ ] ace in the [ __ ]
and everybody else in there got a damn
you know one of those sticks they're you
know beating or whatever looking for uh
you know whatever that you i guess you
just try to beat the
truth out of the air in front of you i
don't even know what they do with if you
have like a blind stick or whatever but
um
or just get the air to tell you
what's
in it i don't even
that whole thing's never made sense to
me but um
anyway
i'm losing my train of thought
but yeah so i wanted to see what was
going on man so i started and i couldn't
find like an exact
place that i wanted to go and i didn't
know what for
uh
i just knew that i wasn't feeling good
so i just decided to go to meetings i
started going to meetings um
for
uh
like
they're basically like sex and love
addiction but the real thing you're in
there if
that wasn't my thing i don't have a sex
addiction
but i do have like a uh
i noticed an addiction and a
interesting relationship with um
attention
and admiration female especially female
admiration
so i started going to a lot of meetings
about that and i started going to a lot
of aaa meetings i was going to two
meetings a day
um
just to be social just to have like a
social environment that was like um
a place where people were sharing their
thoughts and feelings
you know because i really would i really
got intent on trying to figure out what
is what is
why is there something in me that's
always you know
that's always
in pain kinda
and i'm not trying to have a pity party
or anything i'm just trying to share
what happened with me
so so anyway i got it i got into um
i saw i was going to meetings i was
doing that and i was off the
antidepressants and it's wise
dude
you'll be talking to somebody and like
somebody will pat you on the back and it
just
it feels like a pat on the back you
never got and you just start just
tearing up and
it's real
you sent you all your feelings that
haven't been doing anything that [ __ ]
has been milling around some of them are
pissed
some of them have been doing damn oxygen
i mean you know they're doing oxycontin
some of them are on pre-workout
you know some of them have been in zoo
culture there's a lot you know they've
been milling around
so you got all these feelings once
you're off antidepressants i did anyway
and i'm not telling you to get off them
don't do anything that i do ever
and maybe you know talk with a doctor
but yeah i went to i talked to the
doctor and then i weaned off and that
was that so
and i started microdosing psilocybin
you know because that's like an
alternative
so uh
you know i i got like a
whatever dose you're the dose you're
supposed to get and started doing that
um
and i started working my step work and
in different programs and different
recovery programs um
and then
so i don't know who was talking about
ayahuasca
and it could have been either neil
brennan or
um
uh
jason ellis i know we spoke about it
when he was in with tony hawk
and
i talked with neil about it oh and a
friend of mine
uh
a couple friends of mine went
brittany schmidt a comedian she
performed with me somewhere she went a
couple people went
and
and so next thing you know i'm i got
signed up i got signed up for ayahuasca
man and uh
so i was going i was seeing my therapist
i'm telling my therapist this is what i
want to do and they were in support of
it and so
like a lot of therapy and like i was
getting some pretty good traction with a
lot of my feelings and things that were
making me upset
and then i had this moment during the
holidays too this was a big part
where
you know a lot of my ish a lot of my
stuff has come from you know uh
i think childhood neglect really
i didn't know when i nobody was really
tickling me nobody was looking at me and
loving me
and i'm not complaining
you know it hurts me
but i'm not really uh i'm not here to
complain about i'm just telling you what
happened
so
i was home for the holidays
and
i was down by my mother's house and
you know i'd really just been struggling
and i had a lot of feelings because i'm
off these antidepressants and
um
and i'd kind of been keeping my distance
from my mother
there's something about the relationship
that's been tough for me and i don't
know what it was
and i just needed some space
um
and i went down to her place and i was
sitting there
with her
talking and she giving me a gift
and uh
and i just broke down man i bro i'm just
sobbing i mean just saw just like
damn just like niagara like somebody
like some
you know like some damn real estate
wizard had moved a little
you know
eight square inches of niagara from
canada right down onto my face in
louisiana
and i'm just bawling
uh just really just
just suffering honestly just
just just a lot of stuff i think from
just probably being young i don't know
and uh
and my mom she didn't say nothing she
didn't
come and put her hand on me or say
anything
so after a few minutes i've you know i
got myself together and uh
and i asked her i said well dang ma you
know
i said it seemed kind of strange that
i'm sitting there really suffering
and um
and you didn't check on me you know
and
[Music]
and she said
oh i thought you were just really taken
aback by the gift that i got in you
and it was a nice gift there was like
some vitamins or you know some damn
vitamins or something it wasn't it was
thoughtful not i'm not this isn't i'm
not judging my mother
uh and i'm not criticizing her
but
it just
i realize then there's just some
disconnect there's something where she
does she there's some inability for her
to express
the type of
affection or attention that i would need
from someone in that position
and then it started hitting me that this
is the way it had always been my whole
life
my whole life i've been wanting
just somebody to be there when i
suffered or when i was hurting or
anything and nobody ever was when i was
a child there was no
you know i don't have any memories of
being hugged i don't have any of that
kind of stuff
from growing up
uh
ever
you know and i'd always thought that
maybe if i do something if i behave a
certain way if i achieve a certain
achievement
then i'll get this will this
something would change in my
relationship
um
with my mother
[Music]
who's my biggest fan by the way i mean
she watches the podcast every week and
you know
and i love her for that
uh
but
there's just some there was something
that there's some
and she even sent me a message
she texted me later and
and we spent time over the holidays
after that and stuff but it was just a
real telling moment for me that man all
my life this is how it had been and i
always thought there was something wrong
with me
but there's just some disconnect she
just probably no one had ever done it to
her
when she was in pain or when she was
hurting
nobody had ever
taught her you know had been loving
towards her or whatever i don't know
but
anyway
uh
so that was like a wild you know that
was just a heavy moment and it was a lot
of things
it made me
realize that there was nothing i could
do anymore
to get
there was nothing on earth that i was
going to be able to do to get my to get
what i needed from my mother and i'd
always thought there was
i'd always thought that i'd just get
[Music]
you know
even with comedy with with everything
i thought you know maybe
if i can get everybody in the world to
love me
then maybe i'll get my mother to love me
and it's not that she doesn't she loves
me
it just
the elements that
that i need to be loved the way i need
to be loved or that a child does
no one probably maybe did them to her i
don't know i'm not judging her or
anything this isn't a judgment
um you know i'm not trying to talk bad
about her
but it just was uh
no one did i i don't know she doesn't
have that it's almost like a blind it is
like a blind person they can't see she
can't
do it
she can't do it and it had never been
more evident to me and in my whole life
i'd never realized until that moment
where i'm sitting there and i am like
man i was just really
just bubbling
you know
and there was no reaction from her
um
or there was no
i'm sure she was hurting for me but
there's just she doesn't have that thing
where
the ability to comfort
you know
i don't know and some of that i'm still
learning i don't know everything
but anyway so that was a wild thing you
know and that was a lot because then it
made me like a lot of anger
i was like man my whole life
this is how it had always been like
everything made so much sense to me now
like
why i'd spent my whole life i'd always
become such good friends with my
girlfriend's mothers and with my friends
mothers and like i was always looking
for this
for this thing
for this connection that i just had
never had
you know and it made me even think when
i was a little kid that i probably was
really struggling and nobody was right
there you know
and maybe that my mother even saw me
struggling but didn't have the thing
inside whatever that is
and i don't think it's a choice that she
made i just think it's a it's some
it's like almost like a autism
um
it's like an emotional autism
and i'm not judge you know i can't do
all this and like
you know there's part of me that'll
always be angry and stuff but i'm not
you know this isn't about being angry at
my mother
um
i can have that time but
it's like being angry at somebody who
can't uh
who can't eat chocolate or for not
eating chocolate but they don't have a
um
a mouth or a tongue
and so you're sitting there just yelling
at them for not eating chocolate
but they don't have a mouth or a tongue
so anyway that's a lot of information i
didn't even know if i really wanted to
share that and i don't know uh
i don't know if it's the right thing to
share i never know what the right thing
to share is sometimes you know
um
[Music]
but i'm just trying to tell you where
i'm at there's other i'll tell you other
great stuff i'm going to the super bowl
um
that's going to be exciting you know i'm
going to try to pop down to mardi gras
uh
but then so but i want to tell you a
little bit more about what happened but
also i got to tell you um
that
we got some uh tour dates i got to do oh
and i did in ayahuasca i did ayahuasca
so that's where this kind of
heads to
and um
anyway i'll get into that in a second
but here we are right here we got this
the tour dates uh rockford illinois
february 25th chicago illinois february
26th
lafayette indiana and tulsa oklahoma are
sold out
los angeles may 7th
and those will all be um
theovon.com
tour
and get your tickets through there don't
go to these other
aftermarket sites they put a damn you
know they put some rockford fire skates
on it they put a dirty spoiler on it and
now they're selling you to ticket for a
thousand don't do that
um
[Music]
what do i want to tell you okay right
now we got to do this
if you're struggling with something
and you need some help
it can it can work for you better help
that's right
if there's something interfering with
your happiness
you can't get that big smile from god
freaking
you know you can't get that bad signal
of the lord to hit you in the heart
uh then betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours but that's beautiful damn that's
under two days
that's only you know
that's two breakfasts and you got help
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
join the over two million people who've
taken charge of their mental health go
to betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
uh
with the help of an experienced
professional
special offer for this past weekend
listeners get that ten percent off maybe
that d count
get that d count
off your first month at betterhelp.com
theo
that's right the um
uh this podcast is sponsored by better
help
we also want to let you know about
draftkings the moment we've been waiting
for since september is finally here in
honor of the big game draftking sports
book
an official sports betting partner of
super bowl 56
is giving new customers 56 to 1 odds
damn that's almost
that's
that's a lot
on either team bet just five dollars and
get 280
80 in free bets if your team wins
draftking sports book is now live in new
york
meaning you can bet from almost a third
of the country that's powerful
new customers can get a free shot at a
one million dollar top prize with their
first deposit
um it's also live uh
in louisiana now too
i just did a video for them download the
draftking sports app
use promo code t-h-e-o get that 56-1 odd
on either team
that's right that's promo code t-h-e-o
at draftking sportsbook 21 plus minimum
age and location requirement vary by
jurisdiction if you struggle with
gambling this won't be for you
so know that
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for full list of requirements
state-specific responsible gaming
resources
for prohibited gaming problem
call 100 gambler
in tennessee or text call or text the tn
redline that's for gambling
1-800-899-889-9789
in connecticut maybe if you're up there
in connecticut baby and you you can't
you wagered at all baby you bet the baby
if you bet the baby
on the buffalo bills then you get you
know you lost it that's okay go bills
but call 888-789-7777
or visit ccpg.org
chat in new york call one eight call 877
h h o p e n y or text h o p
n y
hope any
ho hope new york
that's right and we'll help you
[Music]
so anyway that's i had a lot going on i
was going through step work i was uh
you know i was
uh doing really good therapy man i gotta
finally got a great therapist that i was
working with and
i was just having conversations that
were real because i could access my
feeling man my feelings had been like
goldilocks and
you know they'd been sleeping in my bed
but i wasn't home baby you know
[Music]
my feelings had been
i mean it had just been this long game
of hide and go seek
and now they were right there but it was
also
dude i was having i mean i had
afternoons where i wanted you know
it was really tough
and there's some moments where it is
still tough
uh
but it was it was man it was really
really tough there was moments man where
i didn't want to be a lot bro
there was moments where i didn't want to
be alive man honestly and i don't say
i'm not trying to be negative i'm not
trying to tell you that i don't
you know that i don't love myself or
anything but it just
it hurt
you know i've been on antidepressants
for 18 16 16 years
so
i there was a lot of stuff
um
you know and i don't even know if i
should have shared that story about my
mom i've been
kind of wondering if i should have
shared it i don't want
i don't want
my mother to think that i don't love her
um
but i just i do want to be able to share
what
go because all the all these years i'm
sharing about how my feelings are having
i'm having a tough time and then now i'm
able to get a moment where
oh i see what's going on here
i see why my all like why i uh
why every time i see like a woman smile
something about it make i have to
i need that
you know if it's you know
why the attention of a woman it might
everything in me turns
i remember one night at the comedy store
uh
i think joey diaz had been up there bro
and he was down
he was on you know 7 000. he was on some
damn uh
you know he had he was wearing kneel
diamonds around his neck and he had damn
um
you know probably 80 000 millibursts or
whatever in him
of you know something magical
he was just spinning baby he was up
there just neil armstrong and with no
helmet baby you know what i'm saying
he's that mars daddy bro he was nipping
on neptune
he was sitting on saturn baby he was out
there
diy moon landing dawg
um
and i remember i had a great
conversation with him we'd just been
chatting and having a nice time and
then i walked out on the porch and there
was this pretty there was this
attractive girl
and
i tried to get her attention i couldn't
really get it and
i saw her a little bit later in the
evening and
and i tried to get her attention i just
i was afraid to approach her
and
uh
and then she
i don't know i started talking to
somebody and then they she left
and i was so
the fact that she hadn't engaged with me
or meant to talk or just or that i
hadn't engaged with her something about
it
not but no blame on her but just the
fact that i wasn't brave enough to or
whatever something about that just that
i don't even know who i don't i have no
idea who she even was
but something about that moment i
remember that was a night this was years
ago but it was a night that i relapsed
it was a night where i just
i threw in the towels bruh [ __ ] i threw
in a whole load of laundry dog
so it just shows me that there's like
it's something about affection
and a ten if if there's some necessity
necessary or necessary uh
not necessary but some need for an
attention
um
that has a profound effect on me and
always has always has
um
and now i could see why because i there
was this thing that i was never getting
and when i saw it between my friends and
their moms when i saw i wanted to it
made sense why i moved out at 14 why i
got emancipated because
i needed something
you know i needed to be lo i needed to
be seen and i needed something
i needed something uh
and this isn't i'm not i'm not
i don't need you to feel sorry for me
i don't need that
i'm just trying to share my story and
it's scary to even share it because i
don't even know exactly what my story is
but i'm just trying to share you know
the first question on this thing that i
wrote down is what uh or that the
producer wrote down possible topics of
discussion how did you spend your
january
so
then i got ayahuasca
somebody i talked i don't know neil
brennan um
different people i was talking to had
done it
i got on the phone with aubry marcus and
he was telling me the
it just sounded so much like i needed
something different
and i needed something to look forward
to man because i didn't want to get back
on the antidepressants
uh
and when ayahuasca came on you have to
be off antidepressant for 30 days
you got to have a 30-day reprieve baby
so i'm like oh my god i'm already been
off for like 40 days
i have to this is i got to do this
because the winner i'm cuz i'm thinking
about getting back on and i still am
because damn if i feel
like gene bruh
i feel like gene in the sun
man i just realized that i feel like
damn gene
i was wondering man i i was wondering
why that story was coming into my head
wow sorry man i just i
that's how i felt
being off antidepressants i was missing
my skin man
i was missing my skin
dude i remember i stopped at a damn
starbucks i was crying this was a crazy
moment i was sitting there my friend i
was like bro you got him i'm bawling on
the phone because all these fee all this
years worth of feeling
coming out just
anything
i see some dad walk across the parking
lot with his son and it just would
spiral me
all these feelings that have been
trapped
behind this medication
and that might not be what it's like for
everybody this what it was like for me
but the craziest part i remember i
invited or one thing that was crazy i i
was
i was having a moment man and i had my
buddy meet me over at uh
my friend tim great guy
meet me at uh starbucks
he's like just meet me somewhere man
what's going on
and so i meet him and i'm like i'm just
you know
[ __ ] i'm being a and it's not even on
being a little [ __ ] it's just this [ __ ]
would've been in me
so once you're off the medication it's
like somebody lights the fuse and it's
like the fourth of july but all the
fireworks
are old [ __ ] and like uh
they're all [ __ ] there's no fire i
mean they're fiery but then [ __ ] got
a lot of salt water in them baby there's
a lot of weird feelings you know
so i'm sitting there and i'm just
emoting to my friend tim and just
telling what's going on and some guy
drives past his like kind of
bumper-to-bumper traffic because i'm
facing out from the starbuck on a
busy street
and he yells out he's like he honks home
he's like gang gang
and i look up at him and my face is just
riddled with tears man
but
anyway man uh
anyway so i wanted to do into ayahuasca
so i signed up
i signed up man and um
and that was scary
i was excited about it because i had a
goal
because i didn't know how long i could
be out there off those meds without some
type of a goal
you know i was going to meetings every
day uh
and i'd really kind of isolated myself
over the over the years in some ways
something inside of me i had made me
very angry
i was in conflict with a lot of people
i mean the reason i did all of this even
got off the meds and i was just
desperate
man i was desperate for something
different i couldn't honestly i couldn't
go on living
uh
i couldn't go on living like i was
living
you know and that's scary to think man
when your life is going
i mean you look at my life it would seem
to anybody like man
and i i i was
in pain i don't know why
exactly i'm not sure
i'm still figuring it out
but i was in pain i was trying to be as
grateful as i could
and um
but i didn't feel like myself anymore
i didn't feel as whimsical i didn't feel
as
i didn't feel like myself
oh
anyway
i don't know man you know i don't know
if i should have shared all this and
but i want to be able to share my truth
you know and uh
and i got to realize sometimes my truth
is i see other people and they're doing
great they seem happy they're doing well
and this and that
and so i don't want to be me then
i want to be them
and so sometimes i don't share my truth
because
i guess because i i sometimes i don't
know what it is
and sometimes i'm afraid that people
won't like it if i do share it
or they'll judge me or
and i don't want to be the person that's
always not feeling good that's what i
had also kind of become in some ways in
my in some ways
um
so
but that also propelled me to want to
get better but i just
uh
i don't know everybody loved me and i
didn't love me
and not everybody but
a lot of people love me and i didn't
love me and i didn't know what was going
on um
so i got to i got to the ayahuasca baby
and damn bro
damn boy
mother nature's got some hard tits baby
and she breaks them out
and she'll put dude
mother nature break out of damn penis
and let you slur i mean she really
she'll let you slurp on it dawg i mean
i'm just saying it is ayahuasca is like
it's going to god's garage baby
it's going to god's garage
i didn't know i had no idea
i had no idea man what it was going to
be like
and i did the [ __ ] hell dude some people
go to damn china or you know not china i
mean they're doing
whatever
they're doing the damn cough bad or
whatever over there they're sucking on
but um
aye y'all
i did
yeah i mean the place some people go to
chile or
costa rica
you know foreign honduran somewhere
you know
i went right off the interstate man
in los angeles i mean this you could
almost hear the cars going by sometimes
and it was with a group it was with a
really uh renowned group
and that and i it came highly trusted
from a couple friends
and uh and so i went i signed up
and you go in there and everybody you're
in this big circle and every they have a
bunch of altars kind of built with all
these different little
it doesn't feel wick and it's just about
like doing nate just like really getting
back all the gods are on the altars all
the most famous gods anyway um
you know
uh
yeah all the famous gods are on there
and so you know there's that and then
just you take the you drink one meta you
drink another and i didn't know anybody
there
that's how desperate i was there was
another one that was like 10 days later
and i was like i don't know if i can get
to 10 days later
without either getting back on
medication or uh
or just i don't know if i can go i just
don't want to wait
i don't want to wait
and uh
so yeah bro so i you know i took it and
you're sitting there and it's really
like a meditative thing
to me it seems like a meditative
meditation additive
because you're kind of sitting there
and i'm trying to think more about
oh
and they're playing beautiful music i
mean damn
like somebody stole uh
jesus christ or gabriel's playlist or
whatever they somebody snagged it
you know like somebody beat you know
like somebody squeezed uh
beethoven's eardrums right into the
speakers i mean they're just
they're playing beautiful music
and uh
and
and yeah and you're sitting there and
then this you kind of start to meditate
and the next thing you know your
meditation kind of just goes to a new
place and man
i started crying i started emoting tears
just i mean
just damn like i was a dispensary like i
was uh you know a suboxone clinic and
i'm just this shit's just dripping out
of my face maybe like methadone this
[ __ ] is just
i mean people just kept pressing the
serving button
and i'm just
like when you do that extreme wash at
the car wash and that they you know the
big blasters come on bam bam bam bam bam
bam that's what i was that's where i was
at
and my just tears just flowing out of me
just grief years of just
grief coming out of me
and little things start to come up it's
like honestly it's like god just kind of
tells you the truth in a way
in a comfortable way though
it's like a best friend you always
wanted kinda
and i just started re just certain
things came up in
inside of me and that were really real
things um
certain moments and memories uh
um
dude yeah and i would go drink water
like three or four glasses of water and
then i wouldn't even have to pee later
and i'd get thirsty again because i was
just bawling i mean just like
some realizations people that i needed
to make amends to
you know uh
an ex-girlfriend came up in it and it
told me that oh you know i really had uh
neglected that relationship for myself
part of me wanted me to try harder in
that relationship things like that where
you're like oh wow
it's almost like your heart gets to talk
and your heart says like hey
i really this i really wanted
uh this happened
um
and you really are talking you start to
talk to like this inner child you this
is how this this part sounds wild to
some people but
you start realizing that there's this
like the young you the little you
is always been inside of you and alive
and
yeah it was i mean it was powerful man
it was real powerful
oh
i'll tell you a little bit more about it
let me think more what i can tell you
about it and if you have questions you
can always hit the hotline 985-664-9503
um
here i got to do uh these other ads man
and then i'll tell you a little bit more
about what happened man oh
i'ma let you know about upstart
upstart what would you do if you didn't
have any high interest loan or credit
card debt
would you move to a new city would you
start a farm maybe
do a little farming with your cousin
hit a little ass all we want to farm and
now you you know
he's always leaving seed on your
doorstep
and whispering you know uh baby carrots
and
in
in your wife's ear thing like that you
know beets
lettuce
you know
milo corn you know what i'm saying so
maybe that could happen
if you had extra money if you got to pay
off your existing debt
with a personal loan
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
t-h-e-o that's upstart.com
theo don't forget to use our url to let
them know we sent you
loan amounts
they'd be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
t-h-e-o
i also want to let you know that uh
if you need a new website they'll help
yep
if you don't want to spend thousands of
dollars on a new website
you don't have to
we didn't
at theovonn.com we got that hitter put
together baby from modify modiph
you can say baby
to overprice logo designs and old-school
contracts you get unlimited updates
it's uh 4.98 to start but
if you go to modify.com
theo you get fifty percent off your
starting cost
so that's a deal m-o-d-i-p-h-y dot com
slash t-h-e-o they'll build you a
website there's no cancellation fees no
hidden fees ever
free revamps unlimited updates it's 249
a month after the initial cost
we use it and we love it modify.com theo
um
the ayahuasca was really i mean it was
just you're sitting in a circle and
people are bombing
people are emoting they're sharing you
know like sometimes people are laughing
you're just going through
it's like your heart and your brain and
god serve up things that
i don't know all types of things
um
man i'm trying to put it into words it's
really hard
uh
and the music is so beautiful your brain
will just go off on like your heart will
really just go off on a tangent it's
almost like your heart gets a
brain um
and there was some different things i
realized i realized that if i
well i realized a couple of a couple of
kind of sad things popped up like one
was that
at some point when i was a child i
wanted to be a girl
uh because i thought if i was a girl
then maybe somebody would love me
you know um
and that come it bubbles up and it's
like it's such a real
when i realized that it broke my heart
because it's sad to think that
it's sad to think that there's a child
out there who
thinks that maybe the thing that's wrong
with them is what everything that they
are
you know and at some point in myself i
thought that about myself
i thought that at my very core my
masculinity
that i was wrong i was
broken or whatever
um
or that if i if my if maybe if i was a
different gym if i had been a woman then
maybe my
parents would love me or whatever
whatever i needed would be provided
uh
and that so things like that will come
up and it's such a real thing that's hid
there's no way it couldn't be the truth
it's so it just grips you
and that was really heartbreaking so
things like that come up and you're kind
of grieving them
so i'm just sitting there bawling and
i'm kind of suffering you just kind of
cry in silence like and everybody in a
circle is doing it
so it's not like
uh
and then there's these people that are
like angels that are like there's a
shaman sorry this isn't it's not like
everybody's just like on a zoom you know
we're listening to some you know a book
on tape there's a shaman
and he's like kind of leading the charge
and
man it was amazing
it was amazing and then there's these
moments where if you really are
suffering and the shaman i guess sees it
they have these these workers that are
with the sham and he sends them over to
be there with you
and i remember one time i looked up and
there was this there was a young woman
sitting there with me and just sitting
and they don't say anything
they just sit with you
and
when that happened i bro dude i on i
mean it was like man
i really unloaded because
all my life
i just wanted somebody to be there with
me
while i
hurt
i just didn't want to hurt alone
i didn't need somebody telling me what
to do i didn't need somebody telling me
how to feel i didn't need somebody
telling me what would what i could have
done better
so that i wouldn't have been feeling the
way i did
which is probably what i got
i got a lot of growing up i got a lot of
you need to do these chores you need to
do this you need to do these things you
need to take care of yourself
but i never got any of the
i'm here for you
no matter what
i never got an ounce of it
so when this person came and sat there
then i blew up again i'm like oh my god
all i ever wanted was somebody to be
there with me
while i
wasn't feeling good
and so it's not even adult stuff it's
just lit moments from childhood that are
just trapped in you
and a lot of those with the ayahuasca
baby then things come ripping i mean
they are they're like fireworks they
come ripping out of you what is this
plant
god dang
sorry got a fake plan here saying 119
and this [ __ ] won't leave me alone
here
get away from me
um
so man it was just powerful it was a lot
there was a lot of things there's things
i'm even embarrassed to even say man
um
you know because i don't want to sound
like a wimp
ah
and that's okay you know uh
you know one thing i've noticed about
myself my whole life i've shared
i've just i've needed affection i've
needed some
attention i've needed people to care
because i didn't have it and so
anything has been negotiable for me in a
weird way over my life
and some of this i want to share because
i know there's a lot of guys out there
that kind of struggle with similar stuff
that i do
you know i see it in their eyes when we
meet after the shows or we meet before
the shows or
people that come up to me and say hey
you know i see it
i don't think i'm a rare case in the
world or nothing like that um
you know
and look i know that a lot of this is
all over the place it's it's still all
over the place for me
that was about two three weeks ago and
i'm going again in a week and a half
to do it again
um
i've had friends tell me that they did
it a certain number of times and then
they never needed to do antidepressants
again
i don't know if i'll be able to get
there
you know i think uh
you know i don't know i'm trying
so
um that would be nice
but if not then maybe i'll i'll have to
get back on something and that's okay
too none of this is a judgment if
anybody's on a pill or anything look
part of me still doesn't know of whether
if i should have just got onto a
different pill or something but
i don't know if i had another choice the
the pain in sodomy was
it was coming out of me it was
breaking through it was like i was angry
i was miserable and
and i don't know if if i'll be able to
fix myself i don't know
but
i feel like i'm out here i feel like
literally whenever they drop that
astronaut off on the machine up there
whatever it is some satellite and he's
gotta fix it or whatever they give him a
wrench or whatever that's how i feel
i feel like i'm out
trying to fix
this
you know uh
but i'm now working with another
therapist i'm doing emdr therapy
um
and i try to when i look back in my
history i've tried a lot of stuff to
feel better i've tried a lot of recovery
i've tried different 12-step programs
i've tried
ketamine
i've tried yoga i've tried different
medications i've tried uh
like a
gut biome thing like
um
uh
so i'm proud of myself for trying
i'm proud of myself for trying bro
you know i'm no soft boss dawg another
thing i got into in the past month was
uh jujitsu
and that's been helping
that's been helping because you know i
never had a father growing up and this
isn't a woe is me there's people's
stories out there that are oh
that are really harrowing
but the only story i have is my own
um
[Music]
and it's okay if my life doesn't fit you
know
everybody whatever every other people
are doing you know
i can't
pretend anymore i'm not where i'm at
you know um
because it's not fair to me either
it's not fair to me either to not to per
to be somewhere that i'm not really at
sometimes um
um
so yeah i mean a lot of other stuff on
the ayahuasca like your
your inner child is right there so you
see all these things you you did as a
kid to set yourself up for success
so one thing i realized was like as an
adult if like as a child i took a lot of
l's like i set myself up like i went
through a lot of
grueling moments by myself
so i could be successful later
and so
i'm living my childhood his dreams i'm
living my those are my kids dreams that
i'm living right now
they're not really my adult dreams
they're my
but my childhood dreams i'm living his
dreams
and when i look at that it gives it puts
my life in a little bit of a different
space
um
it makes me really proud of who i was as
a kid
which
is different for me because i never felt
proud
all i ever felt was if i do something
different
or what can i do differently to be loved
that's all i ever felt
so then the only way i developed any
sense of myself was by reactions to what
i did
so if i started getting loved by people
then that's who i was
i was
whatever
i was whatever it
i needed to be to be loved
and somewhere along the way some of me
didn't really develop because i didn't
know who i was
i don't know if i felt safe to be out in
the world i'll probably
you know
i'm sure at a really young age it wasn't
real i didn't feel safe
i felt like whoever i was
it wasn't okay to be that because i
wasn't getting the return that i needed
um and it was a lot of pressure on my
mother my dad was you know a senior said
he was always he wasn't around and that
was very scary and
you know a lot of [ __ ] like that but i i
i'm not trying to get into all that
again but um
but yeah so i'm just kind of on this
journey i'm still in the middle of it
oh
and yes sometimes i'm ashamed i'm not
ashamed i just
it's scary for me to share some of it uh
because i'm scared i think of what
people think
i don't i you know
which is what i've always been my whole
life
probably
i'm scared of what people think of me
if i'm myself you know
but some cool you know a lot of neat
stuff and a lot of adventurous stuff and
you know because i would like to be able
to have a family i want to be able to
fall in love one day and and have a
family and some of that
you know a lot of this old [ __ ] keeps me
from doing that it keeps me
and i don't want to do it and then not
you know anything can happen who knows
if a relationship could do well but i
don't want to
i don't know i just noticed these spaces
in my life where it's hard for me
it's really hard for me um
and one of them is in relationships and
jujitsu has been cool because i get to
go there and and people help me
you know it's like
i can be vulnerable and be like i don't
underst i don't know what i'm doing in
this moment in this physical moment
and instead of somebody ju you know like
sure somebody gonna tap me out
somebody tapped my little ass out bro
damn i mean dude
one guy put me on like a damn clip on
tie the other day but damn
some dude put me on like a damn uh
cummerbund that dude had me he was
headed to prom bro
and i was an accoutrement that dude
freaking wore me down
but um
but
there's moments in there where
a guy will help me do something
without judging me or without uh
giving me any energy that i'm not good
enough
and i never had that in my life i didn't
have no father i didn't have never had
that
you know when i was talking with uh with
dustin the other day with poirier and he
i was telling him that i said man it's
just such a magical type of thing and he
said man i know exactly what you're
talking about
so i know that there's a lot of dudes in
there uh
you know and i'm okay man one of my
strongest muscles is my is my is my
heart
you know and i've always been that guy
where i got you know
i got tears in my eyes but barbell's in
my hands bro
that's always been who i am and i'm not
ashamed of that um
but that's been really cool man that's
been fun it's been fun for me to be in a
place where i feel safe
uh
and also not safe at the same time bro
and i tapped a couple clowns out baby
that fred astaire boy i put it on him
dawg that hard scarf
some little piglet some little pork chop
i [ __ ] put him in a [ __ ] deep
fryer dog
praise god
um
this show isn't all about me this has
been a lot
uh
there's more stuff
um
i want to get into just quickly into the
news
the beijing winter olympics hit by
deluge of complaints from athletes
freezing conditions they're complaining
about
[ __ ] it's the winter olympics
you can't complain about freezing
conditions
if you do in
the winter olympics
that's like
being at a hooker house and complaining
that
somebody's touching your neck
okay
you can't
you know what i'm saying like they got
what else they saying uh
they've been served the same thing five
days in a row for breakfast lunch and
dinner [ __ ] that's chyna
have you been to china i was on a train
in china a girl opened up a bag of
bird feet
and ate them
betcha
and guess what
she was a [ __ ] hot chick
so you're in a place where hot [ __ ]
is eating bird feets
do you know that
did you google china [ __ ]
go get find something in your house
that's falling
apart that's china dawg
that's china
okay that's what we sold america for
so don't be shocked when you go to china
and [ __ ] gets china
[ __ ] gonna get china in china
the big air ski jump at the olympics
looks like it's set next to a nuclear
power plant
it is dog
it don't look like it it is baby
get that huff off the air baby that's
god trying to gas you up son
if you think you could jump far regular
imagine if you got that nuclear
in your son you might jump your way all
the way into a [ __ ] dirty bat cage
baby
it's china dog
china going to china
you can't be in china and be shocked
when [ __ ] gets china
come on man damn
behind the skiers launching themselves
at the 60 meter high foot ramp are
furnaces tall chimney stacks and cooling
towers yeah
uh
yeah [ __ ] that scenery [ __ ]
that's scenery
dude that is damn scenery bro
bro i remember one time when i was
growing up dude we had a bike ramp right
and the best place for it
in our area was right by this
pedophile's house
which he got to sit there and watch us
you know he's sitting there over there
like he had a damn delicatessen bro
he picking [ __ ] future touches out of
his teeth
but
that's the location of the deal
so you can't be shot man if you go to
china and [ __ ] gets chinatic
you can't be shocked man
y'all complaining too much y'all
supposed to be olympians
bruh
[Music]
y'all could handle this if y'all
olympians y'all could handle it
male arrived 75 years late to new jersey
home well that sounds like the mail dog
have you even been to the mail
shock wanda back there
you give her the thing you say overnight
that [ __ ] shows up
in a decade dog
have you even driven by a po the [ __ ] is
crazy now
this [ __ ] is crazy in there
a bunch of bird houses people selling
bird cages out front
they doing nails in there now dude my
buddy opened up his mailbox the other
day put his foot in the thing and
somebody in the back painted his nails
bruh
that's the us postal system
that [ __ ] is gone
that [ __ ] is gone dawg
and if you look we'll i'll cut to this
clip right now from the andrew uh
uh schultz episode if you want to know
more about it here we go
u.s postal system [ __ ] is right it's 50
50. remember trump tried to fix it and
then america was like stop
this doesn't work and they're like stop
there and he was like he's like no you
understand like it's just handed it to a
black guy and maybe he brings it and
then they're like stop
trying to make it better you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you thinking he's like
but maybe there's a better system even
for them like we could give them an
address or something to get your postage
to and america was like [ __ ]
you
for wanting us to get our mail
piece of [ __ ] yeah are you crazy guy
dude the anxiety do you think a white
male [ __ ] traveling around the
country anymore this [ __ ] has to stop
dude but just imagine being that poor
black guy they just give you a satchel
full of [ __ ] and he like do you know
where where any of this should go
deliver it
yeah but i was just wondering if if i
should
should know where is there like a route
and there you
go uh
let's get a couple of voicemails that
came in from you guys man this show's
about you as well 985-664-9503
and uh
yeah thank you guys for listening man i
i don't know what that you know
i don't know
but
that's kind of what happened man in the
ayahuasca was just
it
relieved so much it just
it feels like there's an opportunity for
some real relief
i could see it being one of the
greatest things that happens for people
in the future uh for getting better
i really could um but that's also with
me try this is early
you know i'm gonna try it again and
we'll see what's up
um
what else
who do we got right here let's hit one
what's up theo this is michael and i got
my girlfriend hannah
she's right here next to me
what's up michael what's up hannah thank
you guys for the call baby we just got
done at the jacksonville show we're
actually driving back right now
and that was actually our first comedy
show man we've ever been to it was like
the best experience ever
and we just want to say thank you for
hanging around taking pictures with
everybody it means the world to us man
we don't really get to see many people
like you
but uh yeah man gang gang
gang gang baby thank you guys man
yeah at some shows i tried my best to to
pop out and sometimes it's a you know
it's a i'm exhausted i'm just
socializing exhausts me
um i think i've needed a break for a
long time and
and even though i just took a break it
was also a lot of work this break was a
lot of emotional work bro oh
but anyway man i'm grateful i got to see
you guys and yeah it was it's fun dude
uh
and those shows were good man
because it took so long to get to
florida because dark arts tour started
in florida
so
that material i think the show is 90 now
new stuff
um for there
but now some places you know we added in
stuff so it's always a little different
but uh but yeah man that was magical
we're gonna make another run through
florida soon to some different cities
and um
yeah i'll put some other stuff on the
books uh
gang baby leave me here here's another
call that came in
hey ceo what's up man my name is justin
i'm a big fan
finally got to see you in orlando this
weekend and you absolutely crushed it
i appreciate uh introducing me to maddie
smith she was hilarious she had us
pulled out of our seats and then you
came in and just uh finished us off no
homo
anyways i wanted to make a comment um
your peers brandon brian i think some
other comedians they kind of [ __ ] on
orlando a little bit and uh i don't
think that they've ever gotten the real
experience but anyways i thought maybe
you could uh
give orlando a good word and maybe get
some of your your friends to give it
another shot
well look
when you go there and do champion [ __ ]
like i showed up and did you have a
different experience
if you showing up doing mediocre stuff
dawg if you out there peddling uh you
know
uh
you know thick biscuit recipes or
whatever then boy you know or [ __ ]
alopecia treatments or whatever them
boys came to town to do i don't know
but we showed up and put the roll
in rock dawg
we showed up and did it right is orlando
weird yes it's weird okay it's really
weird there's a lot of sunlight there's
disney
it's a you know it's a great you know
there's long the days are longer there a
little bit it's a pedophiles you know
it's the produce section for a pedophile
fresh as it gets baby so
it is weird bruh but
damn we gave it hell baby
uh all right let's get another call that
came in man
theo what's good man uh
struggling a bit right now
you know i looked to you
and looked up to you
when i was getting clean
and given up uh
giving up that space of the dark arts
you know what i mean and not letting it
control my life anymore
um
and i guess just
and needed to vocalize it man and i'm
beating myself up a lot i
feel like i felt my kids my wife again
but
i uh
i relapsed
the other day um
not sure what to make of it uh guilt
shame and
you know everything else that falls in
line when that that happens man and uh
you know
if you had any instances like this you
know
they could share
kind of what it was that they got you
over that hump and made you not even if
you had this one flip up you know what
yeah brother thank you for the call man
and yeah i think just sharing it with
someone
so you're not feeling you're for just
for yourself you share your feelings now
you got more than one person
carrying the load um
i uh
yeah i've relapsed man a bunch
i've fallen back i've tried i've not
even known if certain programs are for
me and i've restarted the programs you
know um
i just got through
nine steps in one program man and had to
start over
um
you know uh
it's
it's a journey man
it's a journey you know what is not you
know
you're you're never gonna tell your wife
or kids or think to them that you didn't
try you're not trying
so
i don't know the only thing i know is
that that the i do believe that those
programs work um
and
it's okay
i'm not like uh
i don't want to condone you not giving
it your best effort but you can only
give it what you're willing to give it
you know people get better when they're
able to get better and when they're
ready to get better and
um
and i'm sorry man i'm sure it probably
hurts that you
are having to start over uh or have had
to and
um
[Music]
but you're not a bad guy
you know
and
you're not alone
[Music]
so
yeah just try again
if you feel like trying again
you know
um
i just want you to be happy
you know i just want you to live in a
space where you're happy
and i just want your sibling your kid
you know i don't want if you have kids
man i don't want you to miss out on them
you know
[Music]
one thing i do want you to do i whenever
you spend time with your kids man i want
you to
look them in the eyes
you know be there with them
let them know you love every single
thing about them
even if you got a name every single
thing don't name the freaking
you know penis or you know what i'm
saying don't name like the dirty parts
but they're not dirty but don't name the
crotch
but you know what i'm saying you know
name the things about him you love name
the characteristics about them you love
get that in them
get that in them man
but look man you sound capable
and i appreciate you sharing what's
going on with you and not just keeping
it to yourself and uh
it's a journey bro
don't beat yourself up
but lift yourself up
if you can and uh
and if you need help ask for it
you know dude i'm getting some my
calendar this week i'm angry because i
got to go to so much therapy right now
and [ __ ] but that's okay
i don't you know it's a weird time in
the world
it's a weird time in existence in in in
humanity
i'm a [ __ ] warrior dog
and you are too man you got this [ __ ]
gang baby
um let's hear one more hey brother uh
past month i
lost a best friend
um
aod's on feteno
[Music]
cocaine laced with fentanyl
and
i guess i just
want to know
you know have you ever dealt with any of
these
how did you deal with it how did your
friends deal with it
he's a hell of a man dude
i love him to death [ __ ] that
yeah i don't know how they making
fentanyl dude you know chinese
toothpaste some people say they call it
i don't know what it is i don't know
much about it
but uh
but yeah dude it's scary i've had a lot
of friends overdose in the past few
years
um in the past two years i think six or
seven
uh
you know
um it's heartbreaking
it's heartbreaking that that's where we
are in the space of humanity where
that's how much we love each other that
there's things like this out there
it's heartbreaking that we are
feeling broken as human beings
um
we may realize in the future that the
diversion out of like being tribes and
out of the woods and into society was a
total
wrong move and we may end up back in
[Music]
you know in the trees man
um
i don't know
oh
but it is scary man i'm sorry for your
loss
i'm sorry for your loss there was a guy
who used to do the audio for this
podcast named sherb and he took care of
the audio for a long time and
uh and he the same thing happened to him
he overdosed uh on some bad pill or
something and
i still think about him it breaks my
heart
i don't really know an answer
you know but i appreciate you sharing
and letting us think about your friend
with you for a second
um
and just be good to yourself man
i bet that's what he would want you to
do
you know when uh and just we got to
battle the dark arts dog
that tour may be over but they they are
out there
we're all doing something i jerked off
yesterday brother and i'm not comparing
that to fentanyl but
you know
it really kills my dick when i do it i
feel like
but
anyway man god bless you god bless
everybody thank you guys for being a
part of my life uh and thanks for
listening to this podcast um
as always you can hit the hotline
985-664-9503
uh
[Music]
what else dude you know i support joe
rogan i think that that i think he's
just a nice i think
i've never known a guy that was more
curious and just tried to communicate we
live in a scary it's interesting out
there how do we battle it i don't know
we'll get into it more in the future um
but uh
what else do we have here
um
yeah let's do this man this is uh
i love this song uh
let's take it away right now this is uh
do more good by the cordovas um
[Music]
thank you guys for being a part of my
life and really truly thank you for the
support
i know some of y'all came out to those
shows even if
you know
when the tours were switching over and
even if
you know some of you might not even like
comedy
and you just came out to show love and
uh
and i appreciate that
and i want to thank you thank you for
loving me
and um
i can't thank you enough
and uh
i'm thankful to my mother for putting me
on the earth
and uh and to my father for putting me
and um
i uh
i um
i'm grateful uh
to be out here battling you know
we keep going baby we don't stop
gang gang dog
gang gang
oh that's the wrong song
we're the young and the sick and the
cold ones just long get out of control
the ones that are calm
and the ones that'll fold
and everyone standing round the table
[Music]
those who have lived with their feet to
the fire and forgave
[Music]
gonna
[Applause]
[Music]
the those and the prideful the peaks and
the eyefuls the ones that just waited
their dreams are all styled for the
roasts too afraid to admit they've been
lied to martyrs
[Music]
that goes double for you
you're gonna do
gonna do more good gonna talk less [ __ ]
i don't know if i'll talk less [ __ ] but
gang gang baby be good to yourselves man
um
you deserve it